très bien bah écoutez chers collègues
mesdames bienvenue au Sénat nous
poursuivons ce matin nos travaux sur la
thématique santé des femmes au travail
avec nos quatre rapporteurs Annick
jacquemay Marie-Pierre Richer Laurence
Cohen et Laurence Rossignol qui vont
probablement nous rejoindre je l'espère
notre première audition de la matinée
consacrée aux professions libérales nous
accueillons pour cela deux représentants
de l'Union nationale des professions
libérales à Minata Niakate avocato
barreau de Paris présidente de la
commission parité égalité à l'une APL et
elizenguyen chargée de mission à faire
économique à une apl également les
professions libérales sont des
professions mixtes avec une parité quasi
parfaite les femmes sont néanmoins
majoritaires dans le secteur de la santé
64% ainsi que parmi les avocats 57% il
est donc particulièrement important
d'avoir une avocate parmi nous ce matin
bienvenue
il est naturellement difficile de
procéder à des généralisations
concernant les professions libérales qui
sont extrêmement multiples les risques
qu'elles sont d'exposer les
professionnels libéraux sont très variés
pénibilité physique pour certains risque
psychosociaux liés à des contacts avec
le public pour la plupart nombre
phénomènes de stress et de Burn Out en
particulier pour les libéraux chefs
d'entreprise ou micro-entrepreneurs
certaines problématiques sont communes
aux professions libérales je pense à
trois sujets en particulier celui des
politiques de prévention en effet les
professions libérales n'ont pas accès au
même campagnes de prévention et
d'information que les salariés qu'il
s'agisse des risques professionnels ou
de prévention en matière de santé en
général un décret du 26 avril 2022 a
prévu que chaque service de prévention
et de santé au travail inter-entreprise
propose de travailleurs indépendants une
offre spécifique de service en matière
de prévention de ces risques
professionnels et de suivi individuels
ainsi que de la prévention et de la
désertation des insertions pardon
professionnel qu'en est-il en pratique
de la mise en oeuvre de ce décret
mesdames et un deuxième sujet crucial
pour les professionnels libérales et
celui de la grossesse les travailleuses
indépendants bénéficient bien d'un congé
maternité aligné sur celui des salariés
depuis 2019 mais en pratique elle peine
à s'arrêter de travailler pendant 16
semaines le montant d'ailleurs des
indemnités versées n'est pas souvent à
la hauteur de la perte de revenus
engendrés par l'arrêt de travail et
enfin plus largement la conciliation
entre vie professionnelle et familiale
chez les professionnels libérales et
déterminantes s'agissant de leur
équilibre personnel et donc de leur
santé psychique et physique donc il
était très important pour nous de se
pencher sur ce sujet avec vous mesdames
et je vais vous c'est descendre plus
tarder la parole en vous laissant vous
organiser comme vous le souhaitez pour
cette prise de parole et ensuite les
rapporteurs et les sénateurs sénatrices
qui sont présents pourront vous
interroger s'il le souhaite je vous
remercie
[Musique]
et nous avons tendance à négliger notre
santé tirailler entre ces différentes
préoccupations peut-être un mot de Luna
PL de ce que nous sommes donc le pays la
France compte 1,7 millions de
professionnels libéraux et l'Union
nationale des professions libérales est
une organisation pas très patronale
représentative créée en 77 par le
regroupement de divers syndicats
représentatifs des professionnels
libéraux nous sommes en répartis en
trois principales familles d'activités
de profession libérales dans le secteur
de la santé on rencontre des médecins
pharmaciens dentistes sages-femme dans
le secteur du droit donc avocat notaire
commissaire de justice et puis un
troisième catégorie un peu plus large
qu'on appelle technique et cadre de vie
et donc on retrouve parmi eux des
experts-comptables architectes agent
d'assurance guide touristiques
interprète conseillers financiers et
voilà notre organisation fédère 68
organisations membres au niveau national
les femmes en profession libérales sont
vous le disiez madame présidente
majoritaire dans le secteur de la santé
64% des chefs d'entreprise dans le
secteur juridique elles sont 57% et
elles sont minoritaires dans le secteur
technique cadre de vie 41
41%, peut-être un petit focus sur
quelques chiffres par exemple chez les
médecins on compte 40%
de médecins hommes femmes pardon femme
parce que les femmes en général médecin
choisissent plutôt le salariat et
en structure libérale on a 59,5% donc
les hommes sont majoritaires en tant que
en tant que libéral et dans les
professions
chirurgiennes dentiste les femmes
redeviennent un peu plus nombreuses 53%
pharmacien 54% auxiliaires médicaux ça
se fait mise beaucoup plus 71% de femmes
chez les vérités urinaires la tendance
se réinverse 42% de femmes contre 57,7%
d'hommes et dans les métiers un peu
technique moins de femmes donc les
agents d'assurance 80% d'hommes
et les experts-comptables 75% quasiment
d'hommes évidemment d'un d'une
profession à l'autre effectivement il y
a des disparités
un petit focus sur notre profession sa
profession d'avocats où il y a une
majorité de femmes et qui a essayé une
profession qui a vocation aussi à ce
féminiser puisque dans les écoles
d'avocat on compte 70% de femmes on dit
que les professions qui qui se féminis
sont les professions qui se qui se
paupérisent et une indication parce que
en exerce sous deux statuts en tant que
collaborateur ou en tant qu'associé ou
en tant qu'installer donc quand on est
collaborateur on travaille pour un autre
avocat et là on compte à Paris pour une
alors il y a 32 000 avocats à Paris
17800 femmes pour 14600 hommes chez les
collaboratrices ont 8500
contre
4760 collaborateurs donc on a plutôt
tendance à être plus nombreuses à
travailler pour d'autres avocats et chez
les associés la tendance s'inverse on
trouve 3900 à femmes associées versus
5600 hommes associés donc voilà on a
plutôt tendance à être marginaliser
quand dans l'accès
à l'association
donc dans nos organisations nous avons
quelques chiffres si et là mais c'est
vrai que le premier constat que nous
faisons collectivement avec les
organisations c'est qu'il y a un
véritable manque de données sexos
spécifiques relative à la santé au
travail des femmes professionnelles
libérales et ça ouvre une première piste
de préconisations pour permettre des
études de sexo spécifiques pour pour
permettre des analyses plus fines sur la
situation des femmes professionnelles
mais voilà mais nous avons quand même pu
glaner si elle a quelques éléments que
je propose de vous partager
une maladie seulement depuis 2021 depuis
la covid finalement qui a permis d'avoir
ce débat mais avant on avait des
périodes de carence qui ne permettait
pas de s'arrêter
et il est indemnités journalières qu'on
touche elle ne permet généralement pas
de faire face à nos charges qui peuvent
être assez lourdes entre les charges
sociales et puis les frais de
fonctionnement de de nos exploitations
de nos entreprises libérales
concernant la prévoyance invalidité
handicap décès nous sommes confrontés à
des délais de carence de 90 jours en
moyenne et voilà et en pratique c'est
extrêmement rare qu'on s'arrête plus de
15 jours à moins d'être vraiment cloué
au lit par par la maladie car voilà nos
clients ne nous attendent pas et pour
changer d'avocats de prestataire
malheureusement donc c'est assez
difficile pour nous de s'arrêter autre
remontée que nous avons de
de nous organisations membres
professionnelles libérales les femmes
professionnelles libérales souffrent
dans beaucoup de professions d'un manque
de reconnaissance professionnelle par
par leur père dans le secteur médical
par exemple les sages-femmes elles
n'étaient pas reconnue comme une
profession médicale ce n'est que depuis
janvier 2023
qu'elles ont réussi à faire évoluer leur
statut et donc dans le rapport avec les
médecins
c'était un peu compliqué même chose pour
pour les infirmières dans dans le tout
corps médical un vrai problème de
reconnaissance que ce soit avec leur les
autres professionnels de santé et leur
collègue partenaires
masculins ou dans les négociations avec
le gouvernement pour faire évoluer telle
ou tel texte dans l'intérêt de leurs
professions
respectives et chez les avocats on
trouve aussi beaucoup d'avocates
confrontés à des situations difficiles
face au plafond de verre dans l'accès à
l'association que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure donc ces vecteurs un peu de
stress et souvent on s'installe et on
renonce à s'associer il faut savoir que
en moyenne les revenus entre une
avocate installée et une avocate
associée peut varier de 1 à 5 donc c'est
voilà et les hommes ont tendance à
gagner deux fois plus leur vie que mieux
leur vie tout au long de leur carrière
par rapport aux femmes et pour en
revenir à la à la protection sociale le
meilleur moyen d'avoir une vraie
protection sociale et d'éviter une perte
de revenus c'est de souscrire
volontairement et individuellement un
contrat de prévoyance voilà lesquels
permettent généralement de faire face à
trois risques majeurs incapacités de
travail invalidité décès ou perte totale
et irréversible
d'autonomie et les régimes de sécurité
sociale des professions libérales sont
le meilleur argument de vente des
assureurs
voilà et
donc il faut une meilleure couverture
sociale pour les professionnels libéraux
mais ça fait aussi des bas entre nous
parce que parce qu'on craint que un
alourdissement de nos charges sociales
parce que qui dit des prestations
supplémentaires dit des chiens
supplémentaires et du coup ça c'est un
petit il y a un petit cercle vicieux
et pour en revenir à votre première
question que je n'ai pas oublié
le présidente donc sur sur la médecine
préventive voilà c'est un très gros
enjeu de surveiller la santé et prévenir
les risques professionnels
des professionnels libéraux ça peut
passer par un dispositif d'écoute ou
certaines professions mis en place des
des mécanismes de remplacement c'est
plus sans les professions médicales dans
d'autres professions ça s'y prête
beaucoup moins donc chez les avocats on
le demande mais c'est compliqué de de le
mettre en place de mettre en place des
suppléances et pour en revenir au décret
donc du 26 avril 2022 donc de de l'an
dernier qui prévoit une offre de service
spécifique pour en matière de prévention
pour les indépendants donc ce texte est
très très méconnu des professions
libérales et puis la médecine du travail
elle est déjà à la du mal à absorber les
demandes les besoins pour pour les
salariés faute d'effectifs et faute
aussi d'attractivité de ces métiers
parce que la rémunération est faible et
concrètement pour la mise en oeuvre de
ce décret assez loin d'être une réalité
pour les professions libérales dont par
défaut c'est l'assurance maladie qui en
a la charge et voilà pour le moment on
va dire que c'est encore embryonnaire
sur votre question sur la la parentalité
des professionnels libérales alors il y
a un investissement un peu comme en
population générale des femmes plus
fortes que celui des hommes dans dans la
parentalité à l'arrivée des enfants donc
les femmes sont plus nombreuses que les
hommes à interrompre leur activité ou à
réduire leur temps de travail voilà le
travail domestique les tâches ménagères
préparation des courses à la charge
mentale
le temps consacré aux enfants donc reste
inégalement répartis entre les femmes et
les hommes professions
libérales les et les professionnelles
libérales qui prennent leur congé
maternité elle s'exposent au risque de
perdre une partie de leurs clientèle une
perte de leur chiffre d'affaires qui
peut être qui peut être parfois durable
avec un effet cicatrice sur l'activité
de de l'entreprise
parfois elle s'expose carrément à perdre
leur entreprise en raison du choc des
maternités sur sur la trésorerie parce
que c'est aussi un moment on a plus de
charges et une loi il continue les
charges sociales continuent et des
suspensions possibles mais c'est pas
c'est pas automatique et les femmes sont
pas assez informés sur la distance de
ces mécanismes
et donc en ces occasions dans la
perspective de la maternité de
nombreuses professionnels se réorientent
vers le statut de salarié et donc
s'éloigne de de la profession donc ça
fait des carrières hachées ça fait des
conséquences sur la retraite enfin ça
fait voilà un peu de tout réalisation
des des femmes aussi de nombreux paires
ne font pas valoir leurs droits alors
congé paternité ce qui l'être posé
l'accueil de nous venaient sur leur
partenaire professionnel libéral qui
doit suspendre son activité bien souvent
et voilà et l'attention sur l'accueil de
la petite enfance le manque de place en
crèche n'aide pas
et lorsqu'une professionnelle libérale
doit s'arrêter le
remplacement pour cause de maternité
permet de maintenir le service libéral
au public et voilà et certaines
professions libérales en cas de
juridiquement ce se remplacement et je
vous disais les professions de présenter
notamment et c'est pas le cas de de
toutes les de toutes les professions
libérales
l'harmonisation des congés des
indépendantes avec celui des salariés ça
a été quelque chose aussi d'intéressant
mais ça a pas résolu toute la
problématique du maintien de l'outil
travail pendant cette période
particulière
de la maternité il y a il y a eu quelque
chose d'intéressant c'est
la possibilité de reprendre de travail
de manière
partielle et donc ça ça même si ça
mériterait qu'il y ait plus de souplesse
parce qu'on impose des jours où on
reprend des jours où on arrête et moi si
j'ai une audience le mauvais jour de la
semaine et ben c'est pas voilà ça manque
un petit peu de de souplesse et puis
vous dire aussi
la maternité c'est une des premières
causes de discrimination dans la
profession notamment quand on travaille
pour pour un autre un autre confrère
donc on se retrouve des situations de
sexisme et désolé je suis encore parlé
des avocats parce que c'est le
profession que que je connais le mieux
et l'an dernier le Conseil national des
barreaux à mené une enquête et dans la
partie de cette enquête relative au
harcèlement et au discriminations donc
les femmes étaient les premières
touchées et plus fortement du fait de
leur grossesse pour cet exercent dans
les dans les plus gros cabinets
[Musique]
61,5% des collaborateurs sont des ont
été victimes de harcèlement ou de
discrimination en lien avec la grossesse
c'est c'est énorme et laquelle
représente 30% de l'ensemble des
discriminations
et
et voilà il retrouve des grimades des
remarques et il y a même un blog qui qui
en ligne je sais pas s'il est encore
actif mais où il y a un certain nombre
de propos rapportés de témoignages assez
édifiant d'avocate collaboratrice qui
raconte leur déboires et les remarques
des obligeantes voire violentes
dont elles font elles font elles font
l'objet et il a dessus en terme de
recommandations
il y a eu plusieurs plusieurs plusieurs
propositions c'est en vérité
l'épisode de la crise sanitaire et
mesure qui ont été mises en place pour
gérer l'arrêt total des entreprises à
démontrer qu'il était possible de
maintenir la pérennité de l'outil
travail pendant un choc et il y a eu de
nombreuses similitudes entre entre les
mesures demandées par pour gérer le
congé maternité et les aides et les
aides covid et ça fait des années que
les profils libérales les demandent et
du coup le covid devenu un argument en
plus la suspension automatique
et le report le report des charges voilà
des indemnités journalières un peu plus
conséquent la possibilité de bénéficier
du
le chômage partiel la suspension des
prêts parce que c'est vraiment une une
période où on est vraiment voilà
bouleversé dans notre corps dans dans
notre entreprise et peut-être qu'un peu
de répit peut être bienvenu dans un
moment où on n'a pas de rentrée d'argent
et tout ça peut être facteur de stress
la possibilité de perdre son outil de
travail et sur lequel en général on a
beaucoup investi avant de se mettre à
son compte peut être une
perspective de stress important voilà et
puis et on souhaite ayant souhaité
évidemment que
la facilité on a un débat sur est-ce
qu'on oblige qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas
porté la réponse on est très partagé
est-ce qu'on oblige les pères à prendre
leurs congés paternité
on le débat on l'a pas réglé c'est très
très clivant mais en tout cas il faut
des mesures plus fortement incitatives
parce que les les perles ne prennent pas
le congé ou vraiment très très peu
et sur sur la conciliation Vie privée
vie professionnelle et l'impact sur
l'équipe personnelle la santé psychique
et physique des femmes ça reste aussi
une question assez liée à la parentalité
la difficulté de concilier vie
professionnelle familiale et souvent le
fait d'interruption d'activités les
obligations familiales alors qu'il
s'agisse de d'enfants ou de parents
de trois chiffres
28% des ondes un peu anciens qui date de
28% des des professions libérales ont
déclaré en 2016 que leurs horaires de
travail ne s'accordaient pas très bien
avec leurs engagements sociaux familiaux
hors du travail contre 18% des salariés
déclarant une conciliation familiale vie
professionnelle difficile
on observe un temps de travail nettement
plus long chez les indépendants les
indépendants
à environ 50 heures chez les
indépendants et indépendants contre 36
heures chez les salariés et le temps de
travail est plus haut chez les hommes
non salariés 53 heures contre 45 heures
pour les les femmes et cette durée
particulièrement longue du travail
elle éclaire les difficultés spécifiques
des des indépendantes en matière de
conciliation et donc ça a des effets sur
leur rémunération
que vous dire d'autre voilà autre
spécificités du travail c'est sur la
prévisibilité des des horaires elle est
beaucoup plus marquée chez les salariés
et et beaucoup plus difficile beaucoup
plus difficile chez les les indépendants
qui ont aussi voilà plus tendance à
travailler le soir le weekend a été
exposé à des fatigues et donc ça a des
un impact sur des
inégalités de revenus persistants
s'aggravant
[Musique]
ah pardon pardon
ah pardon désolé
donc est-ce que c'est mieux
donc je vous disais donc des inégalités
de revenus mais des égalités aussi dans
le partage des tâches de mes sticks
un manque de reconnaissance du travail
des aidants des maternité de la
parentalité
vous dire aussi que le modèle de
référence du cabinet libéral est
beaucoup basé sur la disponibilité
permanente
difficilement compatible avec la vie
familiale et les obligations de garde et
astreintes pour certaines professions
compliquent les choses des durées de
travail très longues une intensité de la
charge de travail voilà cause de grosses
fatigue de Burn Out et puis la solitude
aussi du de la chef d'entreprise donc
homme ou femme qui aussi peut peser sur
les chefs hommes aux femmes
d'entreprises et voilà et puis une
gestion du temps qui sélectionne les
tâches
prévisible donc chronophage et donc il
pèse sur
sur les motivations et la santé des
femmes professionnelles voilà qui sont
sujets à une grosse charge mentale et à
une culpabilité de ne pas être à la
hauteur
j'ai droit à 10 minutes je pense que
j'ai beaucoup dépassé
je sais pas si tu voulais compléter ou
pas
certaines à vous madame peut-être un
Guyenne puisque vous êtes chargés de
mission au sein d'une APL donc peut-être
vous souhaitez compléter le propos et
les sur certains volets
oui peut-être avec le micro et beaucoup
plus près du beaucoup plus fort parce
que je pense que personne sinon vous
entend et même pour la compte-rendu
c'est difficile derrière excusez-moi je
n'avais pas l'habitude oui pour pour
compléter en fait sur
[Rires]
voilà pour compléter sur un aspect un
peu technique
au niveau de des politiques de
prévention
en matière de santé des professions
libérales et notamment des femmes
professionnelles il est vrai que depuis
2018-2020 en fait l'assurance maladie
des professions libérales a rejoint le
régime général
dans le cadre dans un cadre où il garde
quand même un petit peu son
autonomie mais
c'est là que l'on a vu peut-être une
amélioration finalement
des prises en charge en fait
des situations de maladies et
effectivement cela probablement facilité
finalement l'apparition des indemnités
journalières
après après la covid et
du enfin c'est clairement dû à la covid
en fait et
pour l'instant concernant plus
spécifiquement les les accidents du
travail et la maladie professionnelles
[Musique]
il y a comment dire
il y a pas du tout de comment dire de il
y a une pensée sur les accidents du
travail et la maladie professionnelle
des professions libérales
et effectivement il existe une assurance
volontaire et individuelle auprès auprès
de la SEPA mais elle ne nous semble pas
très accessible en fait
et d'autant que c'est une démarche que
là où le profession
libéral doit faire volontairement et
donc
pourtant il y a plusieurs études assez
récentes qui qui montrent que
les ces populations sont sujets
à de la pénibilité au travail et donc
si je peux me permettre
voilà nous avons par exemple
une étude assez récente de la carte
Pinko qui en fait la caisse de retraite
des auxiliaires médicaux qui fait état
de risque
musculo-squelettiques d'hyperstresse
et de risque psychosociaux nous avons
une étude très récente
ordonnée par le Conseil national des
vétérinaires qui fait état de Burn Out
de idéation suicidaire élevée et de
santé physique dégradée les
chirurgiennes dentistes font état de
troubles
musculo-squelettiques et de Burn Out
et
donc il est vrai que
[Musique]
il serait peut-être temps de se pencher
sur sur ces sur ces symptômes quelque
part
et
parce que en fait
et je rejoins ce que ce que disait
madame yakate le schéma en fait de
construction de l'assurance maladie des
professions libérales en fait c'est
construit sur une
un statut stable
du professionnel de la professionnelle
sur des positions de marche du marché du
travail stable en fait qui ont été
plutôt mis à mal ces dernières années
puisque
actuellement on voit bien que les cycles
de vie professionnelle sont beaucoup
plus complexes avec des phénomènes de
multi profession et de transition entre
plusieurs statues c'est à dire que une
profession libérale peut tout à fait
devenir salarié et ensuite revenir
professions libérale
s'octroyer une période de d'arrêt pour
faire du bénévolat et c'est vrai que
le système de protection sociale en fait
a du mal à suivre ces trajectoires qui
sont beaucoup plus heurtées il y a
également des processus
d'externalisation qui concerne une
grande partie des des professions
libérales
par exemple en termes de comptabilité de
conseils de formation de digitalisation
les grandes entreprises externalisent
finalement ces fonctions c'est qui crée
en fait un afflux de ce que on appelle
les professions libéral non réglementé
donc
qui sont beaucoup plus sujettes aux
aléas du marché de leur marché en fait
et
qui s'installe et ben souvent pas depuis
2009 en auto-entrepreneur donc voilà
c'est un phénomène que que qui nous a
beaucoup beaucoup surpris mais pour
lequel on a vu affluer énormément de de
professionnels et et
concomitament au statut de
l'auto-entrepreneur
nous avons vu l'émergence de ce qu'on
appelle l'économie des plateformes qui
avec un phénomène d'ubérisation
qui qui a touché effectivement les
professions qui ont voilà qui a touché
les professions libérales non
réglementées et l'apparition de ce qu'on
appelle de faux travailleurs
indépendants
[Musique]
vous commencez à créer votre activité
libérale
vous êtes en bonne santé
parce que voilà voilà
ça l'a demandé énormément d'énergie de
créer son activité et il s'avère que
quand on fait une une étude h par âge en
fait par catégorie d'âge et bien ce
capital santé se dégrade plus vite
et finalement au moment de de la
retraite la consommation de soins des
professionnels des professionnels
libéraux rejoint
la consommation de soins des salariés et
après la retraite
la consommation de soins des ex
professionnels libéraux
se trouvait être supérieur alors
consommation de soins des salariés donc
il y a il y a vraiment un préjugé sur
la santé des activités indépendantes et
également l'autre
pardon excusez-moi et et l'autre préjugé
contre lesquels on essaie de voilà de
lutter c'est que
la création d'entreprise pour une pour
une femme en activité libérale par
exemple et bien c'est
ce serait un
une panacée puisque étant chef
d'entreprise les femmes ont plus
d'autonomie dans leur tâche pour
concilier vie familiale et vie
professionnelle or pas du tout pas du
tout elles ont elles ont au contraire
une continuité à avoir une une double
journée des une charge mentale très très
augmentée par rapport à leur alors alors
homologue masculin qui se repose qui
continue de se reposer en fait sur leur
conjoint pour s'occuper
des enfants et ça c'est vrai que c'est
un phénomène qui a été démontré par
la part madame Julie landour donc
sociologue qui qui a montré
qu'effectivement la charge mentale des
indépendantes étaient beaucoup plus
forte que celle des des salariés
voilà ce que je voulais ajouter je vous
remercie mesdames pour cette
présentation je vais laisser les
rapporteurs et les sénateurs sénatrices
qui sont présents ce matin vous
interrogez tout d'abord Annick je crois
et puis ensuite Marie-Pierre et Laurence
Cohen ce sont déjà inscrites voilà
merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames pour vos exposés
je reviendrai quelques secondes sur les
vétérinaires puisque c'est ma profession
et justement ce matin en venant j'ai
entendu une émission de radio qui
traitait du stress du burn-out des
vétérinaires des tentatives de suicide
à vous entendre parler pardon
oui oui non mais non mais je suis un peu
surprise quand même de l'évolution et de
vous entendre aussi par rapport à ce que
moi j'ai vécu comme en tant que
profession libérale et ce que j'ai
entendu ce matin me surprend aussi et
c'est vrai que chez le vétérinaire je
sais pas si vous allez les mêmes
chiffres ailleurs mais au bout de cinq
ans 40% des jeunes vétos ne pratiquent
plus le métier qu'ils ont appris pour
lequel ils ont été formés alors je sais
pas si c'est vrai dans les autres
professions libérales aussi si ça tient
à
la nouvelle façon de vivre ou d'accepter
ou de supporter la vie je me pose des
questions aussi dans ce que vous avez
dit
par rapport à la consommation du des
soins des retraités qui sont plus
importants que pour les salariés les
retraités libéraux que pour les salariés
alors est-ce que vous avez pu
voir l'origine est-ce que c'est parce
que quand on est professionnel on se
soucie moins de sa santé quand on
travaille et que une fois en retraite et
ben ma foi on a plus de travaux ou de
d'examens ou de choses à faire ou est-ce
que c'est vraiment une conséquence de la
vie de la vie professionnelle
concernant la charge mentale dont vous
parlez et c'est vrai qu'on l'entend très
régulièrement dans les auditions qu'on
fait je sais pas si elle est plus
importante pour les professions
libérales que pour les professions
salariés je crois que ça tient aussi à
la vie en général quand on a des enfants
une famille il faut arriver à gérer et
ce qui m'intéresserait c'est d'entendre
les préconisations qu'est-ce que vous
nous proposez comme solution parce que
vous avez dressé un constat sur les
difficultés sur
la prise en charge aussi bien que ça ait
beaucoup évolué au niveau des assurances
au niveau des soins au niveau c'est des
assurances volontaires qu'il faut
prendre c'est sûr mais un salarié c'est
déduit de
libéral doit doit prendre des assurances
pour se couvrir et quelles sont les
préconisations que vous pouvez nous
faire parce que finalement on a des
constats mais nous ce qui nous intéresse
aussi c'est de trouver des solutions
pour améliorer la santé des femmes au
travail donc là en l'occurrence on est
intéressé par améliorer la santé des
femmes professant libérales voilà merci
merci beaucoup madame la rapporteur je
pense que je vais prendre déjà toutes
ces questions et je vous laisserai
répondre puisqu'on a une deuxième
audition à 9h30 alors Marie-Pierre
Richer merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames
j'ai deux questions
la liste des professions libérales et
diverses alors vous avez évoqué votre
votre profession mais quelque part en
quoi vous pouvez nous apporter des
données des spécificités qui concernent
les professions libérales dans leur
diversité et notamment
une prise en charge qui peut être vous
avez évoqué beaucoup la prise en charge
des de la problématique liée à la santé
en général mais quelle est la
problématique liée à la santé des femmes
en particulier
et puis bon après je rejoins les
questions qui ont été posées par par ma
collègue vous avez également parlé des
accidents du travail des maladies
professionnelles mais de façon encore
aussi très générale on a eu beaucoup
d'auditions les TMS la problématique de
la charge mentale ressortent
pratiquement toujours souvent en tout
cas toujours quelle est la différence
pour vous entre les les
salariés et les professions libérales si
vous voulez ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est de connaître en quoi
être professionnel libéral femme ça
engendre des difficultés pour pour la
santé merci
on poursuit avec Laurence Cohen oui
merci merci mesdames pour vos propos
introductifs moi je rejoins ce que mes
collègues rapporteurs vous ont posé
comme question parce que
j'ai un petit peu
troublé en tout cas parce que vous avez
eu des propos qui était très généraliste
et qui à mon sens n'était pas vraiment
genre vous avez parlé des professions
libérales de temps en temps vous avez
mis l'accent sur les femmes mais en
réalité vos propos semblaient analyser
le vécu des professions libérales or
notre rapport il est consacré à la santé
des femmes au travail donc c'est
vraiment ce qui ce qui nous intéresse en
particulier et donc j'aimerais que vous
affiner et que on demande nous surtout à
la délégation droit des femmes d'avoir
des statistiques genrées d'avoir des
éléments c'est là-dessus qu'on peut
travailler et donc en fait c'est
là-dessus qu'on vous attend voilà merci
ecoutez merci mesdames leur rapporteur
et les collègues en séance ce matin donc
je vous laisse vous organiser comme vous
le souhaitez pour répondre à ces
différentes questions merci en vous
approchant bien du micro s'il vous plaît
je vous remercie pour pour vos questions
alors sur sur la question sur voilà les
vétérinaires avec une grosse une grosse
proportion d'entre eux qui qui quitte la
profession est-ce que ça concerne
d'autres professions donc on l'observe
effectivement dans d'autres professions
y compris dans dans que ça dans les
secteurs de la santé dans les secteurs
du droit au cadre technique de vie il y
a une vraie mobilité entre d'une entre
un statut de salarié un statut de
d'indépendants et les femmes sont plus
nombreuses à quitter acquitter le statut
d'indépendant de profession libérales
notamment au moment de de la maternité
parce que elle elle considère que le
statut salarié leur permet d'aborder
plus sereinement la question de la
maternité dans la profession d'avocats à
la moitié dans la moitié d'entre elles
des nouvelles des nouveaux avocats
quittent la profession dans les 10
premières années pour devenir par
exemple juriste entreprise et la
proportion
de professionnels libérales femmes a
quitté le statut
d'indépendant en tout cas profession
libérale pour se tourner vers le
salariat et plus important que que celle
que celle des hommes
sur sur la question de de la
consommation de soins ce qu'on observe
et en tout cas les remontées qu'on a de
nos organisations c'est que les femmes
en tout cas ont tendance à s'oublier et
plus elles ont préoccupations plus elles
vont faire le passer le reste
avant avant tout avant leur
propre leur propre santé ou leur propre
santé psychique aussi
voilà une tristesse au long cours
caché derrière un sourire de de façade
voilà elles ont tendance à pas consulter
parce que il y a le le
il faut payer le cabinet à faire tourner
faut payer les frais faut payer les
salaires et cette charge mentale est
beaucoup plus revient plus souvent en
tout cas dans les témoignages des femmes
que vous avez libérales que dans celles
des hommes des hommes professions
professionnelles libéraux
et et c'est vrai que le premier constat
qu'on a fait en consultant les nos
organisations c'est que il y avait un
impensé sur
sur cette question sur la surexposition
des femmes
au niveau de leur santé à certaines à
certaines pathologies à certaines
souffrances au travail et c'est pour ça
qu'une des préconisations que quand vous
fait c'est
de qui est plus d'études
très important et donc tout est
préconisations que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure sur
la suspension des charges sociales la
possibilité de recourir au chômage
partiel la possibilité de suspendre les
échéances de prêt
toutes les aides un peu covid qu'on
pourrait transposer pour ce moment
un peu voilà fatidique des femmes peut
permettre en tout cas aux professionnels
libérales de continuer leur exercice
libéral auquel généralement en tout cas
elles sont attachées et sont bien les
femmes qui sont confrontés plus
majoritairement
à cette assez
difficultés là sur sur la question de la
prévention donc il y a eu un texte qui a
été un décret qui a été pris l'an
dernier il faut qu'il soit beaucoup plus
vulgarisé en tout cas que voilà qui ne
soit pas qui ne soit pas l'être morte et
que
[Musique]
et que voilà la médecine du travail donc
peut-être est plus de moyens d'abord
pour traiter
le flux dans le monde du salariat parce
que c'est leur priorité et pour
l'instant il y a pas eu vraiment de
démarches engageantes vis-à-vis des
professionnels libéraux et des
professionnels
libérales de de manière de manière
générale
et donc et pour revenir sur l'approche
jeanrée vraiment les les on a beaucoup
plus de retours de femmes voilà qui
parle de cette charge mentale qui
subissent le le déséquilibre
vie professionnelle vie familiale les
hommes professions libérales sont
beaucoup plus flexibles et d'ailleurs
voilà ils peuvent plus librement
travailler
le week-end le soir etc enfin est-ce
qu'ils ont plus la maîtrise de leur
emploi du temps et
ont tendance à moins laisser de côté
leur entreprise leur outil de travail
pour s'occuper de de la famille ou d'un
parent ou d'un enfant en situation de
handicap c'est vraiment
très souvent la professionnelle libérale
qui
va mettre de côté donc son outil de
travail et donc ça engendre des pertes
de revenus un stress plus important
puisque les charges de fonctionnement
sont à peu près à peu près à peu près
les mêmes
tu peux compléter oui éventuellement je
voudrais compléter sur au niveau de la
première question sur
[Musique]
les le fait que les femmes peuvent
quitter la profession libérale en fait
les travaux de Nathalie Lapeyre sur la
féminisation des professions libérales à
a mis en avant en fait le fameux éthos
de l'exercice libéral où effectivement
le cabinet libéral demandé une
disponibilité
à toute épreuve du professionnel à
l'époque c'était le professionnel et et
avec un
report de tout ce qui était tâches
domestique tâche familiale sur la
conjointe la féminisation des
professions libérales à mais un peu à
mal cette étoffe de l'exercice libéral
et on voit bien que
les les femmes professionnelles
n'exercent pas de la même façon que que
les hommes ça n'empêche pas que
ça n'empêche pas
que
je voulais juste montrer par exemple que
lorsque
les femmes
par exemple dans le enfin l'assurance
maladie a proposé par exemple aux femmes
médecins dans le cadre de la prise en
charge de leur grossesse une meilleure
prise en charge de des indemnités
journalières à condition qu'elle
s'installe en priorité dans des zones
sous dotées en fait en matière d'offres
médicales
est-ce que voilà et ça pour obliger les
enfin on peut le pas obliger les femmes
à s'installer dans des zones sous dotées
et effectivement profiter de la
féminisation des c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne propose pas aux hommes en fait
donc voilà
et puis le deuxième je voulais juste
compléter sur un point qu'est-ce qui
différencie les problèmes des femmes
professions libérales des des salles
enfin voilà c'est effectivement la
période de la grossesse maternité qui
qui peut enfin il y a une étude en fait
sur les médecins qui a montré que la
période de la grossesse maternité
entraîner une perte de revenus de 30% du
cabinet libéral avec un effet cicatrice
c'est-à-dire que tant que l'étude a duré
au moins pendant six ans il n'y avait
pas de rattrapage dans le revenu des des
femmes professionnelles
et et il y a moult moult moult graphique
et moult étude qui montre également que
des inégalités de revenus entre les
femmes professionnelles et les hommes
professions libérales et on sait que en
matière de santé tout la précarisation
des situations
professionnelles en matière des revenus
par exemple et ben un impact sur sur
santé et le deuxième point donc la
grossesse c'est vraiment le point où
a surveiller et le et les situations de
sexisme
les situations de sexisme que subissent
les femmes professionnelles et alors
alors que les salariés sont relativement
peut-être mieux protégé en tout cas
voilà dans les dans en termes de légal
mais le sexisme que subissent les femmes
professionnelles et quand même assez
important elle doit faire leur preuve Si
tu sexisme qu'elle subisse de la part de
leurs collègues de leurs clients
puisque par exemple en tant que
vétérinaire c'est une activité qui est
encore très masculine quelque part et
bien
les Activités vétérinaires
que vos statistiques reprennent
effectivement les
vétérinaires de tous âges effectivement
il y a 30 40 ans il y avait
principalement des hommes moi quand j'ai
fait mes études on était 10% de femmes
il y avait des hommes mais maintenant
dans les écoles et ça fait quelques
années c'est la proportion inverse il y
a 80 à 90 % de femmes donc très
rapidement les statistiques vont évoluer
alors il est possible que voilà oui mais
ce qui se passe aussi chez les avocats
et chez les médecins en fait
les effectifs scolaires et
universitaires montrent une prédominance
des femmes mais au niveau de
l'installation c'est à mon avis c'est
autre chose et puis ça dépend aussi au
niveau des vétérinaires quel spécialité
voilà on parle de quel spécialité et
dans l'étude alors on vous propose
effectivement de vous de vous passer
l'étude de
du Conseil national des des vétérinaires
qui
qui montre effectivement une difficulté
des femmes
en matière de comportement voilà une
difficulté des femmes face à des
comportements sexistes en fait et bien
écoutez je vous remercie madame Niakate
et Madame Nguyen pour avoir répondu à
nos questions va être obligé de terminer
cette audition puisque nous avons une
seconde table ronde immédiatement
ensuite je vous remercie à la fois les
sénateurs et sénatrices qui étaient
présents et les et les rapporteurs et
ben écoutez si vous avez des éléments à
nous envoyer n'hésitez pas des éléments
genre comme vous la demandez notre
collègue Laurence Cohen puisque nous
sommes la délégation au droit des femmes
et on s'intéresse à la santé des droits
à la santé des femmes au travail voilà
merci beaucoup mesdames bonne journée